in this video we're gonna show you how
Animal Crossing new horizons gives you a
lot of opportunities to be your best
creative self through custom designs
with the custom designs application on
the neck phone you can customize and
decorate furniture clothing your house
and even the ground to make your very
own designs this means there are no
boundaries to how unique you can make
your island in Animal Crossing new
horizons and today we're going over a
few tips to help you with your glow-up
before we start there are a few things
I'll explain now to make things easier
for later first off you'll need the able
sisters on your island and the custom
designs app on your nook phone to do all
the customization you'd like when
resident services is upgraded grab the
pro design upgrade for your NIC phone
from the next stop machine it'll run you
800 Nick miles next in order to download
yours or other players designs you will
need to download the Nintendo switch app
on your iOS or Android device link your
Nintendo account and you'll get access
to the QR code scanner lastly there are
two ways to download designs you can
input a designer code at the able
sisters kiosk or you can download your
scan QR items by hitting the plus button
when you have the custom design the app
open on your Nick phone keep in mind
that you'll need a Nintendo switch
online subscription to download designs
from the kiosk now that we have a few of
the technical things out of the way
let's talk resources once the able
sister shop is officially on your Island
pro designs and the kiosk will become
critical to your clothing design needs
while the regular custom designs can be
used to make basic shirts Pro designs
can be made for all kinds of clothing
styles including different kinds of
dresses and hats if you're like me
you're probably as far as you could
possibly be from being a pixel artists
luckily for us there are so many
talented folks sharing their designs
with the masses my favorite place to
search for new designs is on social
media following the hashtag animal
crossing designs I use Twitter mostly
but I'm sure you can find posts with
that hashtag on other platforms too
here's where the previously mentioned
download methods will come in handy and
make it as easy as possible to dress up
you can browse through other websites
that we'll put in the description below
and if you can't find quite what you're
looking for
there are even converters online that
will turn your favorite images and
photos into downloadable patterns here's
where the QR codes come into play any
pattern you find online or previously
made from new leaves happy home designer
and new horizons can be used will
include the links to our favorite ones
below if you want to give it a shot and
of course for those of you who love a
pixel art challenge the in-game designer
actually has a lot of tools for your use
it is the slower and more tedious way to
design but will no doubt produce
beautiful works of art as long as you're
up for it okay let's get creative my
favorite thing to design is actually the
ground there are a lot of awesome custom
paths and designs that you can find
online I got these paths from artists on
Twitter for my very own Island and it's
perfect for the style that I want I'll
go ahead and include these in the
description too I found these recently
but even since then there are even more
path designs that have been created keep
in mind though you don't have an
infinite amount of custom design slots
so you have to be sure to manage your
space to get as many designs as possible
if you replace a design that's already
on the ground with something new it'll
automatically switch what was on the
ground to the new design if you use the
custom paths in tandem with the island
designer at paths you can make some
really unique layouts for your Island
and if you need any help on the
application of these designs then be
sure to check out our Island designer
guide eventually you'll get access to
even more custom designs by getting
Sable to open up to you
chat with her every day it takes time
but it's worth the wait these designs
can be used when customizing certain
pieces of furniture which brings us to
our last tip customization kits are your
best friend you may notice that a lot of
your DIY recipes are customizable you
can check this by looking through your
Nook phones recipe lists and finding the
paintbrush icon on the top left of the
recipe you can choose from a selection
of preset options or even adding your
own custom designs that you downloaded
however DIY recipes aren't the only
things you can customize certain pieces
of furniture are also customizable even
things you wouldn't expect slap your
town flag sticker on a guitar add a
custom print to a cushion or see what
other options are available for that
fish print you just went from the
fishing tournament you'll be surprised
by how many items in the game can be
customized so take your time fill your
pockets and head to a workbench to add
your own personal touch we hope this
video has inspired you to get creative
and put the I in island it's been really
fun discovering how much more as
possible when you spend the extra time
on custom designs and we can't wait to
see what else the Animal Crossing
community comes up with what's your
favorite design if you have won a share
put the code below for other users to
download we also have a ton of other
awesome AC guides and tips on our
channels so don't miss out thanks for
watching
[Music]